what's going on guys greg and john here
today we're gonna watch from
spider ward new spider-man suit leaked
major spider-man
no way home leaks as everything's
leaking
everything's leaking you know what else
is leaking my car i just got back
after being stranded at the bank for
three hours got the car towed
five minutes after i got back this
dropped heck yeah
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have
some really really big spider-man no way
home leaks
and these come in the form of lego
leagues and
also and you know it's real
spider-man suit so we have the concept
art for the new spider-man suit but the
new spider-man suit is
also shown in the lego leaks lego sets
that are supposed to go out to the
public soon but have been leaked ahead
of time
this happens a lot and they usually are
pretty revealing i remember
the lego leagues for avengers end game
all ended up being pretty much 100
true and they actually gave away the
final scene at the end where thanos
attacks the avengers compound so just
because it's
a lego league don't brush it off they're
usually pretty revealing and this
in particular is very revealing and for
those who are wondering if they are real
or fake
i have seen them on the actual lego site
and i did post that link
on twitter for people to see wait why
were they on the lego site so
let's go ahead and just jump right into
his lack of communication
including two new spider-man suits and a
scene where spider-man
is in the sanctum and of course if you
love the mcu and want to stay up to date
on everything including spider-man no
way home be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification
so there are actually two different lego
leagues and let's go ahead and just talk
about the first one and kind of get it
out of the way
because this one is a vulture and a
spider-man drone fight
now don't automatically just go thinking
that oh this is a scene that's going to
happen because as we can see at the very
top of the box here it says inspired by
marvel studios is spider-man
homecoming so this doesn't actually come
that vulture is going to be in the film
and this is going to be a big
fight scene in no way home but vulture
is most likely in the movie which is why
they are releasing a lego set with him
in it otherwise why release the lego set
but the big part to notice about this
one
is that spider-man seemingly has a new
suit now again this could be nothing
since it is inspired from homecoming but
maybe he does get two new suits
throughout the film because the other
lego leagues that we're about to talk
about
actually do reveal a new suit a new iron
spider suit
and this new set really is the big one
to talk about
this set is not inspired by another
movie it is indeed a set from
spider-man no way home and it does have
a lot in it
wow actually a
mj is there as well and one actually
looks pretty peaceful
peter is on some type of a bike doctor
strange has a
wrench in his hand so it looks like
they're trying to fix the bike his cloak
is flying behind spiderman
wong is on the computer and it looks
like mj also has a wrench or some type
of tool in her hand as well
the spider-man have a spider bike in
this i want the spider bike that would
be so cool
perfect for pizza time if this is
something where they are building it to
you know spider-man's always getting
help from other people to put his suit
together and then here now he'll get
help to
put his special bike together if the
bike is being used they'll weave
parts of the cloak into the suits and
he's got special magic mystical powers
so
like last time you know iron spider then
he's like iron man now he'll be like
doctor strange spider-man
it looks like from this box that they're
all working on this one bike together
yeah yeah wong's researching bike
schematics
mj's jumping in to help even the game
it's an important bike and it's the key
to everything now we knew doctor strange
was going to be in spider-man no way
home we knew that he was going to be
somewhat of a mentor to peter parker
however perhaps he's not so much of a
mentor to peter
now obviously with peter parker's
identity being revealed that he is
indeed spider-man he needed a place to
stay and what better place to stay
than the sanctum looks cozy doctor
strange will be a little bit of a mentor
to peter parker but i don't think peter
is just going to be relying on doctor
strange the entire film which is what a
lot of fans were kind of upset about
they want to see peter finally on his
own
and i think that's what we'll see this
lego league does not represent them
this is peter plus ensemble and trying
to help him with the whole identity
crisis then from there i think the
multiverse blows up and peter and doctor
strange might kind of part ways because
strange is going to have to deal with a
lot and peter is going to have to deal
with a lot as well get on your bike
peter
we all expect the other spider-man are
going to jump in but let's continue to
look at this lego league because
the other version shows something very
different than the peaceful scene that
we saw in the first one
the second version shows a lot of chaos
and it looks like there is some type of
mechanical
scorpion being attacking them i'm going
to assume this is scorpion
because it's green and it has the
pincers and it's got that gold spider
logo it looks like scorpion is actually
going
to attack the sanctum in this we can
actually see that he's kind of managed
to capture
wong we see spiderman is hanging on the
wall shooting a web at scorpion doctor
strange seems to have just come through
a portal and it looks like even mj is
involved in this battle somehow looks
like she's carrying
some type of candles in her hand but we
don't know the actual context of the
scene perhaps she is simply
trying to run away and hide because of
this scorpion he's trying to steal the
bike
mj is in pretty big trouble and doesn't
really stand a chance
but luckily spider-man is there and
doctor strange is there as well
okay so he's saying back here at the
bottom that's scorpio yeah right yeah
yeah it seems like there's going to be a
big fight scene that goes down at the
santorium which is not something i
expected out of this movie
no don't expect a big fight no big
fights no action
it does not just say
but at the bottom of the lego picture
there are only four characters featured
there which would be okay yeah so it's
got to be scorpion
uh sub-zero sonia and johnny cage yeah
crossover we've been waiting for
now this actually poses a pretty big
question and i think this falls back to
a leak that we heard
about a couple of months ago that really
ties everything together but first let's
talk about that new suit
spider-man has a little bit of a new
suit and it does look like it's somewhat
of a combination of
his iron spider suit and another suit it
actually kind of looks like the iron
spider suit from the civil war comics as
paul from heavy spoilers pointed out on
twitter
now spiderman has pretty much gotten a
new suit in each film that we've seen so
far
so we would be foolish to not expect him
to get a new suit in this film however
this suit seems like it is simply the
iron spider suit and perhaps a little
bit more technology is put on it or
perhaps
maybe even some type of magical spell
from doctor strange clearly
in these does it come in more black
mechanical pieces perhaps it's not just
the bike that they were working on
perhaps it's a suit as well mechanical
spider-man
they're trying to put the bike into the
suit do you expect to see him in
spider-man no way home he's banging
anime is that he simply got an
upgraded iron spider suit from happy
tony stark was notorious for making
multiple different versions of
essentially the same suit but each with
her own
little different tweak so he probably
made more than one
iron spider suit for peter parker i will
say like as much as i prefer
watching spider-man in a more grounded
suit one that he preferably
stitches together himself i feel like
with all the craziness that is being
just revealed leaked teased an upgraded
arbor
suit seems like something of the
necessity
and i would be curious that if toby and
andrew are deed in this movie if there
is a scene where they are commenting on
there's gotta have like this super
armored suit i could have benefited from
this yeah i feel like that's how they'll
have their cake and eat it too is you'll
get the classic suits with all the blue
and red you know with the toby and
andrew and then you know you'll have
this new iron spider
yeah with all the black accenting and
yeah all the technology and then yeah
you'll get your joke stuff but it'll
probably also help him with multiversal
you know time and space travel a
thousand percent so it definitely looks
like peter is going to be getting a new
upgraded suit in no way home but as i
mentioned
there also seems to be some concept art
leaked of the new
suit and as we can see here it looks
pretty dang cool it definitely has a lot
more gold on it in fact the emblem on
the chest
is entirely gold and this definitely
looks more like the civil war suit that
we got from the comics
now this actually looks pretty similar
to some concept art that we got for the
iron spider suit for avengers infinity
war however that was pretty cool it's
different as we can see here
the gold gauntlets spider suit to return
in no way home now as i mentioned before
about the lego leaked
scene it's a pretty big deal the fact
that scorpion
is in the sanctum is kind of baffling
the sanctum
is very heavily protected it's not like
they just let random bad guys walk in or
burst in it's protected by magic
yes the hulk came crashing through the
window but he was also sent there by the
bifrost which is magic so either it's
getting
attacked pretty heavily and we're only
seeing scorpion here but there could be
other people with him or perhaps he
attacked from the inside
there was a plot leak that said doctor
strange was actually holding
some multiversal enemies in some type of
magical prison
in the sanctum this league did say that
peter parker was hiding out in the
sanctum but then he
accidentally or intentionally releases
these villains so this
is also an option perhaps they are
attacking from the inside because they
got out of their prison cell which
doctor strange was keeping them in
perhaps somehow they got a portal
through and entered that way either way
it's very interesting that
scorpion although it is a giant machine
of a scorpion got
inside perhaps the scorpion mech is
extremely powerful with a lot of
firepower and that's how it got in but
let's not rule out the fact that it
could have attacked from the
inside and this could be a scorpion from
a different
universe now i know scorpion is set up
that would be a waste of a setup marvel
has set people up before a scorpion
suit man so you never really know
now what i would love to see happen like
a big scorpion
from our universe this mech this
technology this huge scorpion suit that
he's been provided i really wanted to be
provided to him by
norman osborne he is said to be the main
seems likely
he likes green and if all of these other
villains are attacking spider-man it
would be really cool if norman osborne
was kind of providing them with the
means to be able to catch him that's why
elektra looks more green too
i mean deadlines up it's funny i've been
watching spectacular spider-man for the
first time it did have my mind going
with hearing that norman osborne's gonna
be in this
in that first season of how you're
introducing villains that are being
rumored or most likely to appear in
spider-man no way home norman osborne is
directly
involved with helping to design or
create some of these villains
so i'm like i actually you know what i i
started seeing it in my head for live
action of how it could be
implemented here because when i would
first hear that i'm like okay it's a
little much
but when i started watching actually was
watching the spectacular spider-man show
i started going oh wait no it actually
it's starting to click starting to
really see how it could how it could
flow well into
it but all depends on execution of the
live action we'll see
but we'll have to wait and see what is
actually going on however these leaks
can hold us over
in the meantime before we get that first
trailer we don't need a trailer about
these
just more legos you need a trailer
notification
we don't thrive off trailers don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
way to go warren you're on top of it
great video buddy
very fun very spider suit looks sick
looks appealing looks like classic sea
war
excited to play in the sanctum with my
legos yeah
i just really kind of my weird takeaway
is i hope scorpion has an actual
skin suit and not somebody radical
scorpio
yeah iron man essentially i don't want
this that doesn't get me excited maybe
it's a stage one scorpion student by the
end i built you a suit
i built it into your nervous system
right no really yeah
all right guys well what'd you think
about these leaks leave your thoughts
down below they're not that revealing in
terms of like plot i'm like what the
hell you spoil the whole thing you know
yeah like i can imagine he'll go there
and this will happen yeah it seems like
it's probably early on in the movie
anyway but guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to war subscribe to us
click that bell hit that like button
i need to go call aaa again see you guys
you